Henry: Hi!
John: Hi! Happy birthday, Uncle Hank! He’s
not gonna say that, he’s just gonna say
hi.
Henry: Hi.
John: Good morning Hank it’s Thursday, May
5th, 2011; you are 31 years old! It’s Hanko
de Mayo!
So Hank, in the video responses below you’ll
find many amazing birthday wishes from Nerdfighteria.
I’ll be tweeting and reblogging those all
day. Also for your birthday I taught Henry
your name.
Henry: Hank!
John: And today you will also be receiving
a large box full of birthday greetings from
Nerdfighters all over the world that were
mailed to a P.O. box in Ohio. That P.O. box
is maintained by the nerdfightastic Valerie2776,
the two thousand seven hundred and seventy-sixth
Valerie to enter the internet, but the first
in our hearts.
Hank, in a few of those cards you’ll find
a dollar or two. We would like to challenge
you to pool that money and spend it in the
way that, in your opinion, most increases
awesome. So we look forward to seeing what
you do with that.
?And Nerdfighters, if you still want to send
Hank a belated birthday card, that is possible;
just mail it to the P.O. box in the doobly-doo.
And lastly, Hank, as previously noted, it
is Thursday. I chose not to upload a video
yesterday because I figured that the greatest
gift I can give my brother is the opportunity
to force me to do something humiliating and/or
embarrassing and/or unpalatable. So Nerdfighters,
leave your punishment suggestions in comments,
and Hank, when you are choosing a punishment,
I ask only that you not think of the brother
who tried to poison you to death with iodine
when you were an infant or the brother who
repeatedly stole from your piggy bank when
you were a child, but the brother with whom
you have been making YouTube videos lo these
many years.
Alright, Hank, so you’re 31 today. Since
you turned 30, you have continued to publish
EcoGeek.org, the best environmental technology
website on the internet. And you fostered
the career of young musicians from Chameleon
Circuit to Mike Lombardo through your work
at DFTBA Records. In the last year you also
organized and ran VidCon, the largest online
video conference in the world. Frustrated
with the increasing three-dimensionality of
the screens we look at precisely so we can
avoid looking at the actual three-dimensional
world, you invented 2D glasses. You also oversaw
the 2010 Project for Awesome which raised
more than $150,000 for charity, and you wrote
songs about making babies and Phineas Gage
and the fundamental constituent of matter
observed in 1968 through deep electric scatter.
In the last year you made more than 100 videos
that we watched more than ten million times;
you inspired us to support the building of
a well by traveling to Haiti with Water.org.
You created Your Pants more or less overnight
- things that don’t make sense to new viewers!
And you built Phototrometon and the HankGames
YouTube channel and you ran Truth or Fail
and you donated blood twice and two days ago,
you beat Portal 2!
Hank, that’s a good year. And while I know
you’d hasten to say that none of this could
be done without Nerdfighteria, and that’s
true, just like you need us, we need you,
so thank you.
And Hank, not to quote a quote I stole from
my wife and used in my first novel, but while
I understand that imagining the future is
a kind of nostalgia, I still can’t wait
to see what you do with 31. Hank, thank you
for being awesome, best wishes, happy Hanko
de Mayo! I will see you tomorrow! ...is something
I haven’t been able to say in a long time!